بشكل مختصر جدا
استمرت الرايه السعوديه الاولى استمرت
الرايه السعوديه من الدوله السعوديه
الاولى والثانيه وبدايه الملك عبد العزيز
متطابقه في الشكل الملك عبد العزيز في في
حينما دخل الرياض زي ما قلنا انه العلم
كان يحمل سيفين نعم
وبعدين
من بعد ذلك ضمن الى سيف واحد وفي مرحله
متقدمه اقر العلم بشكل الحالي في عهد
الملكه عبد العزيز في عهد الملك سعود
استمر استخدام العلم بنفس المواصفات
السابقه ولكن في كثير من الصور نجد انه
على مواقع الملك سعود عاده في كثير من
المناسبات استخدم نفس العلم بس يستخدم
العلم الملكي الذي يحمل السيفين
النقل الكبيره في في تطور العلم هو في عام
73 ميلادي حينما
كلف الملك فيصل رحمه الله عليه
قبلها بقليل عام 76 كلف لجنه بعضويه
الامير سلطان بن عبد العزيز
والشيخ سته وسبعين قصه قبل لان الملك فيصل
756 نعم 66 عام 66 ميلادي كلفت لجنه
بعضويه الامير سلطان بن عبد العزيز
والشيخ عمر السقاف وزير الدوله الشؤون
الخارجيه والشيخ صالح الحصين
للتفكير في موضوع نظام العلم
عملت اللجنه لسنوات ومن ثم اجتمعت مع
السيد احمد عبد الوهاب اللي هو رئيس
المراسم الملكيه ومن ثم رفعت التوصيات
واقر نظام العلم في عهد الملك فيصل ب 22
ماده فصلت في كل شيء اعلام السيارات
الضيوف والاستقبالات مواقع وضع العلم
محاذير كانت شامله اضافه لان الماده
الاخيره من النظام
اشارت الى انه يكون هناك صدور نظام يعني
نظام تنفيذي وفي عهد الملك خالد في في عام
88 78 ميلادي
ظهرت من سبع مواد اللائحه التنظيميه للعلم
وفي عام النقل الكبرى في عام 82 ميلادي مع
صدور النظام الاساسي للحكم كانت الماده
الثالثه في عهد الملك فهد طيب الله ثراه
واموات المسلمين
كانت الماده الثالثه
تتحدث عن العلم ان العلم المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لونه اخضر يعني النسب
وحددت يعني نقاط جدا هامه
تساند ما كان موجود في في عام 73